i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle on a very busy washington tonight
we'll start off with this
the bigger tent that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
okay here's my message to you if you
read one article this week about our
political parties
it should be this piece just published
by axios titled the great realignment
now the gist is that republicans are
becoming more populist while democrats
are becoming more elitist and if these
trends continue the party of biden and
pelosi is destined for historic losses
in the next few election cycles and not
just in traditionally red states by the
way
shifts in the demographics of the two
parties supporters taking place before
our eyes are arguably the biggest
political story of our time the big
picture republicans are becoming more
working class and a little more
multiracial democrats are becoming more
elite and a little more white
now remember this movement of minorities
toward the gop began in earnest under
donald trump
he grew republican support among black
and hispanic voters in 2016 and built on
those gains in 2020
in fact he closed the gap among hispanic
voters by 17 points according to pew
analysis
hispanics especially seemed to like
trump's no-nonsense approach and his
pro-small business policies
his tone and his language toward
illegals and support for building the
border wall didn't seem to bother him
much
i'm a former chief of police on a border
town i'm hispanic proud to be hispanic
and i'm 100 behind donald trump i am an
american graduate student here at the
university of texas rio grande valley
and i wholeheartedly believe that mr
donald j trump will make america great
again
i was born in tijuana mexico i am voting
for donald trump to be the next
president of the united states
now for their part democrats incorrectly
assumed that the more their party moved
toward big government socialism the more
minorities that attract
talk about a huge miscalculation now
more from this axios analysis the data
show that democrats are statistically
tied with republicans among hispanics on
the generic congressional ballot
according to the new york times siena
college poll out this week
democrats held a 47-point edge with
hispanics though during the 2018
midterms
that is a staggering collapse
we already know biden's approval with
hispanics today is in the toilet only 32
percent now approve of his job
performance according to a recent new
york times siena college poll
so how does this all translate in the
november midterms
well democrats hopes for retaining power
rest on non-white voters remaining a
reliable part of the party's coalition
democrats theory of the case collapses
if republicans make even incremental
gains with those voters even small
inroads with hispanic voters could tip a
number of democratic-held swing seats to
the gop
of course for years the republican
elites here devoted to the bush cheney
worldview they thought they could just
steamroll their opposition within the
gop regardless of how bad things got
their answer to losing in 2008 and then
again in 2012
was just more the same
for the last 15 months i've talked about
the need to get immigration reform
done i have made it abundantly clear
that i believe we need immigration
reform we're a nation of immigrants this
is not the time to abandon something
that makes us special and unique
so they thought they'd nominate jeb in
2016 who would beat hillary
and then all would be well it would all
turn return to the old days
so they were stunned when the voters
rejected another bush in 2016. it turns
out that more immigration endless wars
and more bad trade deals well they just
weren't hugely popular shocker
now we tried to tell them that middle
class workers and families were just fed
up
but the republican elites refused to
listen
well now axios has confirmed again that
we populists were correct and the gop
establishment they were wrong
we actually grew the party we made it a
big tent
they shrunk it
because we've made so much progress
inside the gop we're now seeing a whole
new generation of exciting new
candidates across america like myra
flores and jd vance
right now
are hurting us
we cannot accept the increase of gas
of food a medication we cannot accept
that i'm sick in some of the left
destroying this country and i'm sick of
the rhinos in washington d.c who refuse
to fight back against it
now the gop old guard who claims so
desperately that they wanted to bring
minorities into politics
are are suddenly flummoxed right these
weren't the type of candidates they were
hoping for
you know many of the candidates that are
rising now they got into politics
because of trump
now by contrast you have to consider the
problems on the left
the squad and their supporters claimed
that they were going to fight for the
working people they were going to stand
up to big business and oppose foolish
wars
but they didn't keep those promises did
they
so instead instead of working with us to
build a society that would be fairer and
more prosperous for the average person
the american left has allied themselves
with the bidens the cheneys and the
bushes and the whole rest of the
globalist establishment that created so
many of the disasters we're dealing with
now
working-class people know that the left
is not the answer anymore only the
populists are building a movement that
big tent that actually will stand up for
the little guy
so while the left talks about resisting
the plutocrats they're actually doing
nothing we're actually doing the heavy
lifting just as disney or the chamber of
commerce or liz cheney for that matter
we're not just resisting we're winning
when's the last time aoc or elon omar or
ayanna presley accomplished anything for
the working
class the facts of the last few years
leave no doubt that our policies work
for the average american while the
establishment's policies don't
look at how well we were doing just a
few years ago under trump
look at how poorly we're doing now
so this struggle between our populist
movement on one side and the
establishment along with its leftist
allies on the other
it's the great political debate of our
time
but if the establishment wins the future
of america will be bleak
more inflation more recessions more wars
more crime more poverty that's what they
have in mind for us
that's what their policies are doing
right now and that's what their policies
are going to continue to do always works
out that way but if we win
the next 20 years can be a new golden
age with peace and prosperity broadly
enjoyed across demographic lines we can
end these stupid wars we can put
americans back to work we can have more
productivity and higher wages
streets yeah they'll be safe to walk in
in schools that actually teach useful
skills
we can have a government that promotes
america instead of always tearing it
down
now the media they know we're winning
that's why axios wrote this piece that's
why the media are suddenly trying to get
rid of biden
that's why they remain obsessed with
trump why they keep trying to smear
desantis and other populist republicans
but the press couldn't stop reagan in
1980 they couldn't stop trump in 2016
and they needed a pandemic and a
perpetual witch hunt to stop him in 2020
i fully expect the plutocrat class to
work overtime to try to turn things
around for globalism
soros gates zuckerberg they're not going
to give up because biden's floundering
they're going to double down to preserve
the system that protects and enriches
them
they don't care if you suffer it's
irrelevant to them
they've profited off america's decline
in china's rise
but now it's time to beat them and beat
them badly
to take away their power and return it
to the people where it rightly belongs
so we must defeat them one by one in the
senate and the house
every governor's race in the state
houses and yes even the school boards
no state should be left behind we can't
give up on our fellow americans trapped
in places like chicago or baltimore or
san francisco
a political realignment is underway
and with patience and optimism we're
going to keep building this freedom
movement
and when we prevail
get ready for america's new golden age
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else